c'est le bras cabot formation des
lettres maladroite défaut de postures
crispation sur le stylo elle 6 à 14 ans
et de gros problèmes d'écriture la
handicap dans sa scolarité
parfois je fais souvent des marchands
parce que je trouve que mes lettres au
smat fait quand vous regardez les copier
de mes voisins bas je vois qu'ils
écoutent beaucoup mieux que moi et que
moi c'est chez moi elle le vit assez mal
parce qu'on lui fait tout le temps des
reproches là dessus par exemple en cours
ou quand elle va au tableau les élèves
se moque d'elle il ya beaucoup de
moqueries et
voilà je veux que ça soit quand même un
minimum lisible et qu'elle se sente
mieux elle si et sa mère ont contacté
cette grâce aux pédagogues pour tenter
de résoudre ce problème
il s'agit dans un premier temps de
reprendre les bases de l'écriture
visiblement mal acquise avec elle si
donc on a vraiment axé sur la posture et
la tenue de crayon et forme de bases de
l'écriture donc ensuite ses formes de
base vont se transformer en lettres et
donc dans les séances futur on va
vraiment travaillé sur les lettres
cette professionnelle est aussi
enseignante
c'est lorsqu'elle a découvert des
difficultés liées à l'écriture chez son
propre enfant qu'elle a décidé de se
former aux métiers de graff au pédagogue
ça s'adresse à tous les enfants qui ont
des soucis d'écriture à l'école donc
illisibles trop lent douloureux lors ce
qu'ils écrivent
ça s'adresse aussi aux adultes parfois
qui pour un souci quelconque soit un
choix professionnel soit parce que ils
ont eu un accident de la vie ce qui peut
arriver des avc des choses comme ça qui
devrait apprendre à écrire elle ci devra
travailler un peu tout l'espoir pour
améliorer son écriture une rééducation
parfois utile dès la moyenne section de
maternelle et qui se déroulent le plus
souvent en moins de dix séances et se
sont uniquement quand il fallait